I'm going to share with you a project
that took me 8 years to finally build
our garden trellis which hold our
climbing roses hey I'm handyman Dan with
you can build this many times over those
eight years I felt so much like the mom
and dad in the movie up where they were
saving up for a big vacation and then
life would happen they would have to
break open their piggy bank to be able
to pay for any bills or car repairs or
Insurance you name it this is exactly
how I felt but I kept my dream alive one
day I was going to be able to build my
climbing trellis and that day came
finally in the spring of 2021 so what's
with your dream about building a trellis
I wanted my own trellis for a few
reasons I have very fond memories of my
dad occasionally bringing home a bouquet
of roses to my mom and it was incredible
because every time he did this her face
would light up and she would always do
two things first she would run up to my
dad and give him a big smoochie kiss
kids thank you for the reference to BL
then she would immediately go to the
kitchen grab a vase put the roses in the
vase and put it on the center of the
table for it to be displayed to
everybody that walked by because of
those experiences plus others I've
always been very intrigued by roses yeah
but couldn't you have just planted a
rose bush our garden at the time was
roughly 20x 22 ft so I felt like
planting a whole rose bush would take up
a lot of valuable Garden real estate
meaning I wouldn't be able to plant
vegetables in that spot plus with rose
bushes I feel like you can only really
enjoy half of the Rose at a time unless
you walk all the way around it but
trellis would allow me to more
efficiently utilize my garden space and
by adding climbing roses to it it was
the best of both worlds and of course
you can use a trellis for other climbing
plants but that would ruin my story but
you've never built a trellis before what
gave you the confidence to be able to do
it true I had never built a trellis
before but when I sat down and analyzed
the components of the trellis eventually
I was like hey I could build this there
are only five steps to this build and
you will be surprised at how simple each
step is and after we go over all of the
steps of what it takes to build a
trellis like ours I will share with you
some amazing things that we've been able
to do that we never expected and it made
that 8-year weight so worth it we built
our trellis in the summer of 2021 now
coming up on almost 3 years later with
Winters with a ton of snow some very
harsh winds and some incredibly hot and
dry Summers our trellis is still looking
amazing so why even build a trellis
number one it can as a focal point for
your garden we built our trellis to hide
our ugly stuckle wall our garden area
faces the South and so our stuckle wall
gets really really hot in the summer by
having our garden trellis in front of
the wall it's able to actually cool down
that wall and hide it number two a
garden trellis can act as a privacy
screen for your neighbors number three
the plants you grow on your trellis can
bring a lot more pollinators and good
bugs to your garden and number four my
favorite you get a ton of bang for your
buck with the amount of plants you get
for the small amount of real estate that
it takes up by growing vertically
instead of horizontally for example our
trellis is 19 ft wide the two outside
parts are 8 ft tall and the center
section is 10 ft tall overall we have a
vertical growing space of 170 square ft
now compare this to the amount of
horizontal space that it takes up in our
garden with the Roses planted in front
of it and with it being a foot away from
our wall it only takes up 2 ft in length
and and 19 ft in width that's only 38 ft
horizontally if I were to lay that down
and compare that to how many planter
boxes I would need our trellis would
take up probably a third of our garden
space yeah but you do construction all
the time what makes you think I could
build a trellis let's break down the
simple components that make up a trellis
to hold everything up you've got the
concrete footings on top of the concrete
footings you have the vertical posts
connecting all of your vertical posts
together you've got your horizontal
beams then you've got the inner
structure which I'm calling the inner
frame and your inner frame holds the
mesh or lattice that your climbing
plants will hold on to and attach to as
they grow then if you want to add a
little bit of extra flare to your
trellis you can add some extra trim okay
yeah give me the steps step one is your
design phase one tip I can offer with
this is to design around your final
product for our particular circumstance
I knew that I wanted climbing roses I
wanted a lot of different colors and
kinds of climbing roses and I knew I
wanted it to be a big focal point in in
our garden I wanted our three climbing
roses to grow and kind of mesh over each
other taking a boring old stuckle wall
and turning it into a wall of flowers
amazing I know right one important
aspect I had to incorporate into our
design was to make sure that my Trellis
was far enough away from our wall
because the heat absorbed from the Sun
in the summer months was way too much
and I didn't want to cook my roses So I
placed my trellis one foot away from our
wall and this has allowed enough air to
get behind the trellis and keep the
plants cool step two is to place your
concrete footings a great structure
starts out with a great Foundation make
sure to check out with your local
building requirements on how deep and
how big to make your footings for your
structure I used these concrete cylinder
forms from our local hardware store for
the concrete footings and I actually
went pretty deep because I wanted to
make sure that my Trellis was going to
last I got these really beefy 4x4 post
brackets because they have a hole at the
bottom and they have a hole on the sides
and this would allow me to make a
t-shape with rebar firmly connecting my
post brackets to my concrete yeah these
puppies weren't going anywhere and I
needed this because my Trellis was going
to be really heavy plus all the extra
weight of the climbing roses as time
went on another thing I liked about
these post brackets is it had an inch
standoff and so my posts would be an
inch above the concrete and this would
reduce the amount of water exposure from
rain and snow step three is adding your
structural Lumber this includes your
vertical posts and your horizontal beams
the nice thing is you don't really need
that many tools for this you'll need a
drill and a screw gun a ladder and then
one tool I didn't have at this time but
I wish I did was this post level this
level is awesome because it allows you
to clamp it on to your 4x4 post and then
it'll tell you both directions if you're
level I went with redwood material
because of its natural resistance to rot
for my vertical posts and horizontal
beams I went with 4x4 material because
of its structural Integrity the center
section of our trellis is 9 ft wide and
I knew that a 2x4 would not span that
distance without sagging over time one
thing that will really save you a lot of
time and energy is to lay out all of
your pieces before you install them and
stain them it is much easier to stain
them when they're all on a horizontal
surface I placed all of ours on saw
horses and did two coats of stain on all
sides I used this valpar stain I went
with the Redwood tone and I used it
because it said that for vertical
applications it would last 8 years and I
could not be more impressed with this
stuff coming up on 3 years it still
looks amazing you can save a a ton of
time and hassle by not having to clean
out your roller every single time after
you paint or stain all you have to do is
take your roller and put it into the
bottom of a trash bag spin your trash
bag so it makes it tight and fold it
over and I had times where my paint
roller was still wet after 2 weeks and
this was my own personal preference but
I really didn't want to see many
mechanical Fasteners in my trellis to
connect my horizontal beams to my
vertical posts I used an inch and a half
dowel that I drilled into my beams and
my vertical iCal posts and I used tight
Bond 3 glue because it's rated for
exterior use to drill my dowels I marked
the center of my beams and drilled in 2
in deep I then matched that same hole
into my vertical posts the only caveat
to doing it this way is you need to use
bar clamps to squeeze the posts together
if you don't have bar clamps you can use
Fasteners I also wanted to reduce the
amount of risk I would have of water
seeping into the tops of my posts I made
sure that my top beams covered my
vertical posts at the end step four is
to add your metal mesh or your lattice I
decided to go with a metal mesh because
I felt like it was more durable yes I
could have gone with a wood lattice but
I didn't want to take all the time and
cut all these little tiny pieces I knew
it'd be really hard to get them in the
perfect X shape I was also concerned
about once my climbing plants went on
the trellis that my connection points
between the X's would pop so I went with
metal hog paneling that I got from my
local farming store it's galvanized and
comes in 16t Long lengths which was
perfect for my Center section and then I
could use the extra parts that I cut off
and put it on my side panels to attach
this metal paneling I first had to build
an inner frame in between my vertical
posts and Beams I made it kind of like a
picture frame with mitered Corners I
just took 2x4s and ripped them down the
center to get smaller pieces the list of
tools needed for this step are really
simple you'll need a drill and a screw
gun you'll need metal Clips to attach
your metal mesh and you also need a
reciprocal saw with a metal blade to cut
your metal paneling and then one thing
that saved me so many times was was this
metal platform it made it so much more
convenient to cover a much wider space
than a ladder would to attach these
frames inside of the trellis I used deck
screws by making this wood picture frame
inside of my posts and beams put my
metal mesh on top of it and then I could
use these clips to hold the metal mesh
in place the metal mesh Cuts really easy
with a reciprocal saw and a metal blade
I just used the Sharpie to mark down all
the points that I wanted to cut I would
recommend using gloves because as you're
holding the metal and the friction of
the blade can really heat up that metal
step five is to add any extra additional
decorative pieces to your trellis I
wanted to cover the tops of my trellis
because without these decorative pieces
it just looked really boxy for art
trellis I used 2x6 Redwood Lumber and at
the ends I cut out a little quarter
Circle to cut these quarter circles I
used my grandpa's Compass to put it in
the corner and then used it to scratch
the line that I was going to cut into
the wood then I used my jigsaw and cut
that Circle I did use deck screws to
attach these decorative pieces to my
trellis and and surprisingly they hide
really well I just made sure to make my
2x sixes wider than my 4x4 posts so that
you didn't see them behind it as
promised at the beginning of my video
what has made this trellis so awesome
has been being able to share these roses
what I love is being able to take our
roses and make a very fragrant bouquet
for our house or my kids love taking
them to their teachers but the icing on
my fictitious trellis cake was when my
sister-in-law asked if she could use
some of my roses for her wedding bouquet
talk about feeling so honored that roses
from my little Urban Garden would become
part of a bride's bouquet on her very
special day thank you so much for
watching until the end I really hope
that these five easy steps have helped
you feel more confident to build
something like this in your very own
garden or that you have a little bit
more inspiration on what you want to
build for yourself if you decide to
build something like this let me know in
the comments below how your project
turned out if you found this video
helpful make sure to check out our other
gardening videos I have a video on how
we built our garden arbor I have a video
about a tour of our garden I have a
video about how to install a drip system
or if you want to learn how to build or
fix other things I have a lot of
playlists on my YouTube channel we'll
see you on the next video